si cossette avoue éric merci à nos
arnaud effectivement thomas thévenoud
sur notre plateau depuis la première
fois pour la première fois pardon depuis
sa démission du gouvernement en
septembre dernier on a vu dans le
journal le congrès du ps a lieu ce
week-end vous y intéresser encore oui je
m'y intéresse mais la question c'est en
quoi est il utile ce congrès la
direction n'a pas changé les questions
que se posent les français sur la
politique menée par le gouvernement je
suis pas sûr qu'elle soit posée lors de
ce congrès donc moi ce que je
souhaiterais c'est que les socialistes
s'interrogent sur le sens de la
politique est menée en faveur de ceux de
ceux à qui la gauche doit tendre la main
et ee est acquis
la gauche doit consacrer ses efforts ce
qui j'en parlais tout à l'heure ont du
mal à s'en sortir à s'en sortir à cause
du chômage ont des difficultés de
logement des difficultés de transport de
transport la question des hôpitaux
l'hôpital de mâcon qui est un très bel
hôpital un projet de rénovation très
important que je porte que je défends au
niveau national mais je peux vous dire
que c'est dur en ce moment dans les
hôpitaux publics moi je suis très
inquiet sur le climat social dans les
hôpitaux publics parce qu'on demande des
efforts aux salariés de l'hôpital public
en ce moment dans ce pays qui sont des
efforts considérables il ya des milliers
de suppressions d'emplois
et moi je considère que la gauche elle
voit au contraire remettre des moyens de
la santé publique c'est à dire vous êtes
plus sur la ligne de christian paul non
moi je suis plus écoutés je pense que
ces histoires de motion d'abord les gens
n'y comprennent plus rien on est entre
nous quand on est au parti socialiste
les militants sont dévoués c'est eux qui
font vivre encore la petite flamme du
socialisme ils le font sur le terrain en
allant au contact des gens mais ces
histoires d'appareils de motion de
direction franchement je crois que tout
ça est un peu archaïque
alors vous qui avez fait brièvement
partie du gouvernement quel regard vous
portez là sur ces trois ans de hollande
mais je pense que le compte n'y est pas
pour ceux encore une fois qui souffrent
qui ont des difficultés et 6 à la
mission historique de l'amérique un
frémissement de la croissance mais la
croissance
il faut faire plus d'un 1,5 pour cent de
croissance dans ce pays
pour arrêter de détruire des emplois on
en est loin on en est à 0,9 donc il faut
encore en faire et c'est pas les cent
mille emplois aidés annoncée par
françois rebsamen qui vont changer quoi
que ce soit des employés il y en a déjà
ce qu'il faut c'est identifier les
secteurs économiques qui peuvent créer
de la croissance qui sont des secteurs
porteurs et il faut les aider il faut
partir à l'international j'étais en
algérie la semaine dernière pour
rencontrer les dirigeants
le dirigeant monsieur rebrab du groupe
cevital le premier groupe privé algérien
qui a racheté l'usiné d'oxo à cluny
on discutait justement a beaucoup parlé
mais oui mais les parts de marché que
peuvent conquérir les entreprises
françaises en algérie sont considérables
le pays est en train de se développer
80 stades sont en train d'être construit
des ports partout des autoroutes
on a des formidables entreprises du
bâtiment et des travaux publics et qui
récupère les marchés les chinois mais il
faut y aller il faut que on identifie
les secteurs porteurs et qu'on aime nos
entreprises à aller chercher la
croissance là où elle est et qu'on
augmente cette croissance parce que si
encore une fois si la croissance reste
toujours aussi faible on continuera à
détruire des emplois et la promesse d'
inverser la courbe ne sera pas tenu nous
croyons encore vous mais là aussi il
faut corriger ces erreurs
quand on répète tous les mois que la
courbe va s'inverser que tous les mois
on est démentie par la réalité
faut quand même se poser des questions
en tant que député vous êtes aussi très
sollicité je crois pour la carte
scolaire les arbitrages doivent être
rendus dans votre département c'est la
semaine prochaine le 11
oui vous avez des bonnes nouvelles
annoncées au nom moi j'arrête vous en
solide à bord moi je suis pas le porte
en lui
l'éducation nationale je défends un
certain nombre de dossiers
je défends par exemple j'organise une
réunion lundi prochain avec le directeur
académique à bussière dans un tout petit
village
de ma circonscription je défend
également un regroupement pédagogique
qui est du côté de cluny masihi lournand
je défends des dossiers parce que j'y
crois parce qu'ils ont du sens voilà
justement qu'il ya des orgies and
philosophy passe chacun parfois oui
m'enfin quand vous avez des taux
d'encadrement qui augmente parce qu'on
ferme une classe
vous savez très bien que le service
rendu et l'éducation pour nos gamins
ainsi quand même ça qui doit nous
rassembler quand j'entends qu'on se
dispute sur la réforme du collège
il ya du pour et du contre mais est-ce
que sur l'école dans ce pays
la politique a tellement pervertir les
choses que même sur l'école de la
république on n'arrive pas à s'entendre
alors qu'on sait que c'est la clé
l'école la santé publique les hôpitaux
dont je parlais l'investissement public
quand je parle de la rcea et quand je
tape du poing sur la table en disant il
manque 20 millions pour faire mâcon
pressée les 7 km vers la gare tgv et que
sans ça on ne finira pas cette 1ère cea
dont on parle depuis trente ans où il ya
eu des morts de sur cette portion il ya
eu un mort en 2013 à davayé je tape du
poing sur la table
si je suis plus député qui va le faire
personne c'était en train de passer en
catimini
j'ai soulevé le lièvre vous avez écrit à
ségolène royal die hard et j'ai écrit à
ségolène royal a répondu j'ai écrit à
ségolène royal qui ne m'a pas encore
répondu j'ai écrit j'ai interrogé alain
vidalies qui m'a répondu j'ai rencontré
le préfet de saône et loire je rencontre
éric delzant le préfet de région
lundi soir pour parler de cette question
voilà c'est ça l'utilité d'un
parlementaire c'est de faire en sorte
que sur un certain nombre de dossiers
je rassemble les gens je les fédère
autour d'objectifs qui vont dans le sens
du redémarrage de l'économie
et puis de lancer ans de la justice
sociale moi je suis un député de gauche
j'ai pas besoin d'avoir la carte du
parti socialiste pour être de gauche et
toujours socialiste et il ya plein de
socialiste en france qui n'ont pas la
carte du parti socialiste c'est pas ça
la question
la question c'est quelles sont les
efforts qu'on produit pour aider ceux
qui ont moins de chance à s'en sortir
aujourd'hui je considère qu'il reste
deux ans et qu'il faut mettre les
bouchées doubles pour aider les français
qui souffrent à s'en sortir voilà ma
mission malgré les économies qu'ils vont
faire par ailleurs mais des économies on
peut en faire
mais 11 mais on doit se donner des
priorités écoles
santé publique les hôpitaux la sécurité
et la justice ne sont pas serrés france
regarde
après tous regardent après tous
regardent à ben écoute et non sur
l'hôpital public
je suis désolé sur l'école on a remis
des moyens ça je suis d'accord et je
défend d'ailleurs la politique du
gouvernement qui consiste à remettre des
moyens sur l'éducation nationale mais
sur la santé et sur les hôpitaux
non je prends juste un exemple celui de
l'hôpital de mâcon ont fait peser des
efforts qui sont sur humains et
aujourd'hui les personnels ils n'en
peuvent plus un exemple à l'hôpital de
mâcon
on a un problème et ça fait 18 mois que
j'ai écrit à l' agence régionale de
santé dont le siège est à dijon pas très
loin des studios où on se trouve à son
directeur pour dire qu'il y avait un
problème de prise en charge les
difficultés de santé mentale dans le
mâconnais deux de problèmes
psychiatriques
c'est un sujet dont on ne parle jamais à
la télévision parce que évidemment c'est
un sujet qui nous renvoie à l'intimé
anneaux à nos douleurs à nos difficultés
vous avez des gens à mâcon qui ne
trouvent pas de la place qui sont
affectés à l'hôpital de gap
on va continuer jusqu'à quand et moi on
me répond même pas en face ils ont dit
on va mettre en place un groupe de
travail une réunion ce si sûr jeudi on
me répond même pas c'est pas liées à la
sphère ça fait 18 mois que j'écris bon
il faut quand même que l'administration
comprennent que derrière les comités de
pilotage les réunions qui n'en finissent
plus il ya des vies il ya des vies
humaines
il faut sauver et qu'il faut améliorer
justement le gouvernement s est
visiblement de prendre les choses en
main avec les mesures de simplification
il y en a encore qui ont été annoncées
cette semaine là on va dans mon chemin
tout ce qui luttent contre la phobie
administrative va dans le bon chemin
c'était une petite plaisanterie je suis
favorable à simplification je le suis
d'autant plus qu'il y à un homme qui
s'illustre au parlement qui s'appelle
laurent grandguillaume et qui est un
excellent député l'algérie génération la
jeune génération
grandguillaume du rhin
notre sénateur en saône et loire qui
j'espère aura le rôle très important
pour les régionales qui s'annoncent
voilà des gens de talent compétents et
ils ont en eux une pépite ces gens là
c'est qu'ils savent rassembler
rassembler parce que notre pays il a
besoin de ça il faut arrêter de
s'emmurer pour tous et pour n'importe
quoi franchement c'est plus le moment et
le moment il est à l'union des forces et
cela que je viens de citer ou moins
quand j'essaye dans ma circonscription
autour de projets qui vont dans le sens
du redressement économique de la justice
sociale quand on essaye de rassembler
les françaises et les français mais on
gagne plus vite on redresse ce pays on
améliore la vie des gens qui souffrent
les élections régionales vous avez fait
allusion
françois patriat a annoncé cette semaine
qu'il ne serait pas candidat à nouveau
c'est dommage vous trouvez ça dommage
oui parce que c'était un très bon
président pour la raison que je viens
d'indiquer dire que françois patriat
avait cette capacité à transcender peut
penser qu'il faut un renouvellement bien
sûr et je pense que marie-guite dufay
sera une très bonne candidate
mais je moi ce que j'appréciais dans le
travail de patria c'est qu'il avait
cette capacité encore une fois a
rassemblé donc marie-guite dufay sera
sans doute notre candidate
je pense que en saône et loire jérôme
durain a toutes les chances pour tirer
sept cette liste départementale il faut
du renouveau
il faut de la jeunesse il faut du talent
il faut de l'énergie aussi de la
combativité on est dans une période où
il faut
il faut y aller
mais il y aller ensemble ça veut dire
transcender un certain nombre d'à priori
ouvrir un peu nos ornières bon quand je
vois le congrès du parti socialiste
c'est très bien mais lente reçoit les
gens ils n'en veulent plus voilà un tour
et j'ai pas sélective âge ont rassemblé
gens qu'on n'a pas la vérité et moi ma
voix elle est libre je suis de gauche
socialistes et pas besoin d'avoir une
carte dans mon portefeuille
je dis les choses et j'essaye de
rassembler tout le monde et vous
soutiendrez chasse elle va vous le
demander
vu les circonstances on vous soutiendrez
marie-guite dufay bien sûr moi je veux
la soutenir de toutes mes forces de
toute mon énergie
parce que je crois que la gauche a une
mission transformer la société
améliorer la vie des gens et que cette
mission elle peut la remplir en offrant
un visage moderne en écoutant les autres
en faisant en sorte que tout le monde
puisse participer aussi à la prise de
décision vous voyez bien que les parties
s'est terminée regarder ce qui se passe
en espagne avec podemos on est en train
d'assister à une révolution grâce au
numérique grâce aussi à vous grâce aux
journalistes grâce à la prise du pouvoir
de nos concitoyens eh bien ça il faut le
permettre et moi j'essaye de rassembler
a l'échelle de ma circonscription toutes
celles et tous ceux qui veulent
participer à cet élan il nous reste une
minute pour conclure si je dis que vous
êtes combatif là on vous a vu là depuis
onze ans et demi qu'on bâtit vous voulez
sauver votre peau vous serai donc
candidat en 2017
mais il m'avait déjà posé la question
j'ai moisés parce que mais je n'ai pas
changé d'avis en 25 min mais son fusil
c'est pas possible
mais pourquoi c'est pas possible les
jambes ont jugé les électeurs ils sont
juges s'est mis seul juge
les électeurs et encore une fois ils
connaîtront tous de ma vie mes qualités
en tant qu'homme public
ils me le disent d'ailleurs ils me
disent c'est tellement désolant que l'on
apprécié et bien à moi de montrer
pendant deux ans qui peuvent encore mme
apprécié et qui encore une utilité et
c'est ce que je fais tous les jours et
je peux vous dire que ça marche ça
marche pas dans un dans une optique
électorale ça marche parce que
humainement je crois qu'on peut
rassembler les gens autour de projets
qu'ils changent leur vie et sous quelle
étiquette vous serez candidat mais
ouverts mais les étiquettes c'est pas le
sujet on est on est pas en
parler d'étiquettes ça pour moi mais
bien sûr mais moi je vous le dis je suis
de gauche et socialisme considère
toujours socialiste
voilà je suis un enfant de plus ni je
n'en dis pas plus il se trouve que a
plus c'est justement la fin d'émission
la semaine dernière c'était la pentecôte
et que j'ai reçu un coup de fil d'ariane
pour nom nom de gilbert mitterrand
très bien merci beaucoup c'est sur cette
phrase qu on va refermer cette émission
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
je vous rappelle que vous pouvez voir ou
revoir cette émission sur notre site
internet bourgogne point ans 3 point fr
tout de suite c'est le 12/13 qui se
poursuit avec l'actualité nationale près
de la planète
et